russia's invasion of ukraine initially
tanked the value of its currency the
ruble to the lowest level on record
after the us announced sanctions we have
purposely designed these sanctions to
maximize the long-term impact on russia
but since then we've seen a major
reversal and the currency has been one
of the strongest in the world rising to
its strongest value against the dollar
since 2018. i'm going to explain how
russia's currency has defied u.s and
global sanctions to become one of the
world's best performers this year how
the ruble's recovery is affecting
russia's economy and why the ruble's
strength is affecting inflation growth
and the likelihood of a global recession
well the ruble took a massive hit when
russia invaded ukraine but now the
currency appears to be bouncing back
russia's ruble isn't getting stronger
because market participants are bullish
on the russian economy in fact many
currency traders and brokerages in the
west aren't even trading it juan perez
director of trading at monax usa tells
me that his firm removed the ruble from
their currency list months ago but that
hasn't kept the ruble's value from
changing
after the u.s europe and other countries
announced sanctions on various russian
products and individuals president
vladimir putin responded by restricting
how the ruble could be sold russia's
central bank also raised the country's
interest rate and laws were passed that
forced businesses to hold more rubles
then putin decreed that certain
countries would only be able to pay for
russian oil and rubles prior to the eu
announcing an embargo on russian oil in
late may few nations had banned
purchasing russia's top export so lots
of money continued to flow into russia
and much of it flowed in rubles the
ruble jumped from its low point of
around 150 per u.s dollar after the
invasion to almost 55 per dollar in late
may joseph trevasani senior analyst at
fx street points out that while the
ruble's value has been artificially held
up you don't get a discount because it's
manipulated russia has since removed
some restrictions on selling rubles and
the central bank has cut its rates that
is reducing some of the pain for russian
citizens from the sanctions and cutting
back on the expected economic impact of
the war researchers at jp morgan had
expected russia's economy to contract by
35 percent in the second quarter after
sanctions were imposed in march but the
bank now predicts it will shrink by only
about one-fourth of that that recovery
was boosted by increased oil sales to
europe and asia and a stronger currency
keeping a lid on inflation the improved
economic situation provides some cover
for putin and the russian government to
continue the assault on ukraine the big
picture for the rest of the world is the
longer russia is at war with ukraine the
longer we see shortages and delays for
products like wheat and oil that's
pushing up inflation and adding to
supply chain disruptions
this could mean more high prices for
food gas utilities and much more
it's a tough world out there as hip-hop
billionaire jay-z reminds us he says my
mind on my money money on my mind if you
owe me ten dollars you ain't giving me
nine
that's all for now i'll see you next
time